piles of concrete shards of metal and
heaps of paint those living in mikolaev
are no strangers to the sights of War
surviving each day here is often boiled
down to lock
the wall here is gone four walls are
just gone the governor of mikalayev says
eight cruise missiles slammed into the
Port City this five-story building a
non-military Target blasted open for
more than six hours Crews carefully
sifted through the rubble they could
hear screams for help eventually an 11
year old was taken out alive as he was
being moved to an ambulance he pointed
to the sky and said drone possibly
trying to warn those around him the
child later died in hospital people fear
drones they're loaded with explosives
and used by both sides
Ukrainian officials say an iranian-made
drone often called kamikazes similar to
this one struck an infrastructure site
in the capital region but no details
were shared
for the fourth consecutive day people in
Keith woke up to air raid sirens and
they continued into the evening it is
equally concerning the head of the
international atomic energy agency
talked over one of those warning sirens
acknowledging the fragile state of
Europe's largest nuclear plant there are
days where things seem to be more calm
but then the next day we are again on a
blackout twice this week the plant was
forced to switch to diesel backup power
there are now four independent observers
at the zaparizia plant as the head of
the agency meets with both sides hoping
to convince them to set up a protection
Zone Russia signaled it is open to the
idea but also claims the facility as its
own after illegally annexing the area
while Ukraine urges the world to isolate
Russia Vladimir Putin was in Kazakhstan
pitching his Turkish counterpart on
building an energy Hub Crystal
commencing Global News London